I am thrilled to have here one of the
stars of ant-man and the wasp in
theaters near you on July the 6th a huge
fan Sir Laurence Fishburne hey you -
thanks for coming here really so let's
let's uh let's get into a little bit of
the the sports world sure with you right
off the bat
um you were a narrator for America's
game on a handful of times through the
NFL Films and on the NFL Network
yeah as well folks just reached out to
you and say reached out they asked me if
I come narrate these things I was like
sure you know and the great part was
that they gave me free Super Bowl
tickets like five years which was almost
a waste on me except for the fact that
obviously it's you know it's high drama
I'm not much of a sports fan but
obviously like most people I will stop
what I'm doing to watch a championship
so I was lucky enough to see Pittsburgh
and the Cardinals incredible game yeah
and with the lead changes in the final
moments of those games yes and the I saw
the page the Patriots and the Giants I
think twice twice was Eli doing all this
crazy but those games those Patriots
Giants games were like street fights it
was like straight up like you could hear
them and like the sound of them making
contact is really impressive so you have
a buddy that you would bring my cousin
who is about my age is it as an
encyclopedia of sports all sports
American sports sure and so it was our
standing date for a couple of years
where I would we would meet and we would
go see these Super Bowls we were at the
the game were the the New Orleans Saints
one was in South Florida right that was
a great game I'm just watching the fans
what it meant to fans that had waited
for so long exactly another dear friend
of mine was a New Orleans native and I
gave tickets to him and his children and
I mean he had been a Saints fan from you
know the beginning of the franchise and
it was like a dream come true you know
what I meant so much to the to the
franchise just a few years after Katrina
yeah well that was really a moving it
was momentum he was it was a great
moment for the city and for the team
and you know I'm up honorary new or
linea and I have a little place there
and I like to spend time there so it was
great to be an Emeril Lagasse's
restaurant in South Florida with the Who
Dat nation and everybody chanting it was
just it was great Laurence Fishburne
here on the Rich Eisen show so is if you
could name one sport that you would be
most interested in which would it be the
one I actually enjoy watching is mixed
martial arts and I think it's because
growing up in the Philippines when I
made Apocalypse Now I used to go to the
cockfights regularly and watch the watch
the watch the Filipino cats fight their
birds right and you know I've heard
people describe MMA as human
cockfighting maybe it's something to do
with that I don't know but I enjoy MMA
because it's real drama it's completely
unpredictable you never know who's gonna
win and these guys it seems to me that
they're you know fighting for their
lives
have you gone to any I've been to one
event in Toronto Canada a couple of
years back and it was the fight with
John Jones and gustafson and it was
really really exciting
it's brutal it is well I mean whatever
there's a sport in the word submission
it is submission and tap out you know so
are you a mcgregor person or your mother
I am a huge fan of mr. McGregor yeah I
think Conor is is like a great sports
star I mean his whole sort of Swagger
and his his fashion sense and his you
know his relationship not only to
fighting but to just the world in
general I think he's an exciting
personality to watch and I like the fact
that not only is he you know capable of
talking a lot of but he's also he will
he also has the humility when he you
know when he gets his handed to him he
goes hey you know I got my handed to me
and you know tomorrow's another day he
strikes me as he would be fitting for a
Guy Ritchie movie absolutely smoking
barrel he's fantastic in a Guy Ritchie
movie coming
yeah he be fantastic in any kind of
martial arts kind of movie so were you
into the McGregor Mayweather mixing I
watched that fight yeah I enjoyed that
fight I had a feeling that Mac was
outclassed and just in terms of you know
Floyd's ability I mean Floyd is you know
you can't hit him he's just I mean III
didn't know much about the boxing game
years ago but over the years I've kind
of watched it and and learned a little
bit about it I'm not the hugest boxing
fan but again I will watch a main event
because it's huge drama and so sure that
feeds into my sensibility but I had a
suspicion that Mac was really outclassed
with with fighting Mayweather so have
you been to any prize fights and he I
have I was at the fight that I was at
that fight with Mike Tyson and Evander
where he bit his ear oh yes I was at
that fight I was at another fight I was
at a couple of Tyson place well you
can't we need to go back so you're what
was your reaction when you saw what was
going on and well you know it was it was
really odd
Mike's behavior was a little erratic and
it didn't match up with the guy that I
had met many times in person hmm
and it was a surprise to see it happen
once and then to see it happen again
yeah but but the the freakiest part in
the most memorable part to me was what
happened after the second time I was
with another actor friend of mine who
you might know Billy Zane sure and the
second time happened we got I looked up
and I and I saw a couple of marshals
coming from the exits and I saw that
they were closing the doors and they
were getting ready to lock everybody in
the stadium so I grabbed Billy and said
we're leaving we're leaving now and we
got out just in the nick of time it was
crazy that night too bad for him you
weren't on the set of Titanic online
with his character he could have too
so they did they did they explained what
was going on - to those in the arena but
what the hell I don't know because by
the time they got the rock and Billy
were out of the we were going I said yo
we are leaving and we man so for
somebody who says I'm not that diehard
of a sports man you've been to some
pretty amazing - like like some I've
been to the mountaintop I've been to the
mountaintop and with regard to the world
of you know sport in terms of you know
yeah boxing in football but I've only
been to like to baseball games in my
life yeah my brother is is a Yankee fan
and I hope to one day you know spend
some time with him at the ballpark and
you know Magic Johnson and I are friends
and he's invited me out to Dodger
Stadium since he became we're the owners
of the team and I'd like to go do that
sometime but you know I work a lot too
and in that regard I want to talk to you
after a break in 61 seconds about
ant-man and lost and then just roll down
some of facts that we have read about
you or at least is online about your
career and what you have done we
although we did not see in the IMDB
notes about [ __ ] fighting although
that's not fish bird in 60 seconds
[Music]
all right so Laurence Fishburne is not
watching the World Cup but knowing your
history will just be there in Russia
having the award yes exactly
it's Fishburne Iran the Rich Eisen show
ant-man and the wasp this is a fun movie
it's this is kind of different than some
of the other Marvel movie because it's
got a it's got its it's kind of a comedy
it isn't it isn't it is a comedy first
one was a comedy right really really
funny really smart this one really smart
really funny actually funnier than the
SEC than the first one mm-hmm and the
wasp played by Evangeline Lilly Lilly is
she's such a badass in this movie and
you know Michael Pena is hilarious
Michael Douglas is great Michelle
Pfeiffer is in the movie and it's I had
moments where I was playing scenes with
her and and Michael Douglas going oh my
god I'm I'm playing scenes with Michael
Douglas like I can't even believe that
that's happening even after all you've
done after all that I've done I mean
it's I still you know there are still
people in this business that I admire
and respect and I'm just kind of in awe
of you know not only their work but who
they are as human beings
so these ant-man films first time you've
ever worked with Michael Douglas first
time I've known Michael I mean I met him
years and years and years ago but yeah
working with him was such a treat for me
so what was Brando like on the Sarandon
was was was wonderful Brando was one of
the most um you know beautiful human
beings that I have ever known in my
lifetime how old are you on that I was
14 when I started making that movie and
I was 17 when the movie came out but
later on in life I I had a friendship I
developed a friendship with Marlin and
it started somewhere around the time
when I was about 30 years old and it
carried on and we would talk to each
other periodically like I mean like once
every couple of years we would have
these phone conversations that would go
on for
long time what were they about if you
know they were about life they were
about life and they were about race and
they were about work and they were about
children I mean he was really really one
of the most sensitive and and beautiful
human beings I've ever known
I thought you were gonna say you were 14
when you started filming it in 54 when
you the Xperia no no well I was well
people always people always said I was
14 going on 40 when I was doing the
movie mm-hmm so I finally caught up to
that well we have a few facts that are
listed in your your your bio and we have
a drop for this the first time we've
ever played this on the Rich Eisen show
celebrity true or false we got three
have production value we're at I loved
Laurence Fishburne cool is it true did
you really save Emilio Estevez from
quicksand on the set of Apocalypse oh
yeah yeah that's a true story
what was that it was just you know we
were in this boat and you know he kind
of went in the water and he was not
gonna get out by himself just on the
because he's the son of Martin Sheen he
was just on the sea he was there because
Martin brought his entire family to be
with him while we were making the movie
and Emilio and I are exactly the same
age and so he was the only person my age
that was around so here we are these two
15 year olds and we take this boat out
and we're gonna do our thing and he gets
in the water and suddenly he can't get
out and so so you saved him it was water
or quicksand it's like if it looked like
water to me it might have been quicksand
to him I mean I couldn't see it I just
knew that he needed help was charlie
sheen on the set yeah Charlie was around
yeah
is that where he picked up some awesome
well it's worth Charlie picked up some
of his sort of obsession with all things
Vietnam okay yeah well and of course he
was in platoon yes are you true or false
you're a former roommate of Giancarlo
Esposito who yes on the show yes I am
was Giancarlo and I were very very close
for a long long time in our 20s in New
York coming out of New York City you
know being African American guys who had
the
funny last names and we often went up
for a lot of the same parts and then we
wound up being cast as the leads in
Spike Lee's first feature picture which
is called school daze right yeah yeah we
had him on the show and he's he's
incredibly loved him he's incredible Jim
Crow those incredibly loved him yes and
obviously Breaking Bad is one of our
favorites as well yeah you true or false
Laurence Fishburne you met boys in the
hood director John Singleton on the set
of pee-wee's Playhouse I did I did
indeed yeah what's the circumstances uh
he was working as a production assistant
I was doing my world as cowboy Curtis
and you know here he was he was this
young very enthusiastic guy who was you
know just graduated from SC was trying
to be a filmmaker his writing and you
know wanted me to tell him stories about
working with Spike Lee mm-hm because I
had just done the picture I just
mentioned school daze and yeah we just
we struck up a conversation and he said
I have this thing I'm gonna send you you
know and it's really great and blah blah
blah and I was like okay what when we're
done you know send it to me and a couple
of years after we did pee-wee's
Playhouse he sent me a script which was
boys in the hood unbelievable yeah how
you meet people in this business right
and I'm gonna add an extra true or false
is it true or false that the first spike
Lee joint if you will that you did is
you were in the video white lines that's
correct yes that is true that is true
also how did you wind up in the
Grandmaster Flash I had Maurice Pike and
you know he had wanted to work with me
so he said I'm doing this video where
you come to and I was like deal some
drugs
absolutely the drug dealer yeah in white
line in white lines man yeah
so what what what color pill is that
that was powders ah okay I was bout a
different type of a pop but I had some
pills here for you
[Laughter]
in the last one your first credited role
dr. Joshua Hall and one life to live
actually Josh Hall wasn't really a
doctor as a kid yes my first it was it
was not exactly the first one but it's a
so proper that I did when I was 11 years
old like I got this job doing a soap
opera called One Life to Live but I had
done a television movie before that what
was that it was called if you give a
dance you got to pay the band and I
played a character whose name was fish
which is my nickname which is what
people call me okay and and then I had
done some plays earlier on I started
doing plays theater in New York I did
like maybe two plays in 1971 1972 is
there anything that you want to do that
you're interested in all kinds of things
I'm a director and I'm a producer so I'm
also a writer so sir you know I've been
developing Paulo Coelho spook The
Alchemist for about 20 years I've been
trying to bring that to the screen okay
and I'm I'm feeling like you know I'm
almost there something that I've been
asking actors actresses then they come
here I want to ask you what is your
remote drop movie Laurence Fishburne
where you are if you're watching
television and you're just have the time
to just surf through in a movie doesn't
matter where you find it or what how
deep you are into it you know that
doesn't it's gonna be two hours left
there's three of that you drop the
remote what are those three it okay
there's Lawrence of Arabia okay there's
to Sir with love and there's the
Shawshank Redemption the Shawshank
Redemption is one of your favorite right
there look at you and Laurence Fishburne
Brockman what do you love about the
Shawshank Redemption um I love the
passage of time there's so much time
that happens and I love that it's you
know it's a great bromance right it's
these two men who come together who
develop this very very loving friendship
over the period of you know 40 or 50
years or whatever it is it deals with
the American penal system both
characters have an arc they both change
you know from the men that they are at
the beginning of the story to the end
and then the other thing that I that
just is kind of really special to me is
when you think about Morgan Freeman's
performance in that movie if the movie
had been made during the period of time
in which it takes place in the 1930s he
was playing the James Cagney part and
that just for me as as an actor as as a
man of color it was really inspirational
because it's like he plays the Jimmy
Cagney part that you know he wouldn't
have been cast in the Jimmy Cagney part
then yeah I mean Stephen King wrote it
for a wife's Irish man right that's why
his name is read that's why his name is
read but the fact is that he's you know
he's just as Irish as anybody right you
know do you have a favorite sports movie
Lawrence oh yeah I do have a favorite
sports and that is God how can I forget
this my favorite sports movie is miracle
with Kurt Russell about the American
hockey team it's it's so good by the way
that's so nervous at the end that
they're gonna lose and my favorite
moment is that moment there's two
favorite moments for me the favorite
moment I have is when he's making them
do the suicides yes and the one player
finally gets it and goes I play for UTRA
Team USA that moment and then the moment
when they win the game and he goes off
by himself and he's sort of in the
catacombs of the stadium and he's and
he's just doing that that's right it's
it makes me brings me to tears every
time I'm getting goosebumps she's just
talking about that's my favorite sports
movie and I again it's just those are
the ones that were again you know the
outcome we're still on the edge of yours
and then my other one is slap shot as I
played roller hockey as a kid in
Brooklyn
I played roller hockey I couldn't really
like get to the ice skating rink gang
but I played a lot of roller just we
just played roller hockey on the street
in Brooklyn when I was growing up and so
maybe that's why those are my favorite
sports my fantastic
check out ant-man and the Lost Paul
Rudd's on the show tomorrow yeah Paul's
wonderful man he's a good dude yeah his
and I appreciate you coming your
this time you're up for we just
scratched the surface on the stuff you
okay I'll be happy to come back yeah and
you know maybe next year after you go to
another Super Bowl is Super Bowl like
another fight for an ant-man and the
wasp in theaters near you on the 6th of
July the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience